good morning hank it's monday july 4
2011. it's independence day here in the
united states and today i'm going to
talk about financial independence
specifically how young people can turn
their crappy summer jobs into hundreds
of thousands of dollars or the
equivalent in euro
pounds real yen whatever by the way i
think i'm dressed up and giving
financial advice because i was in the
wall street journal last week which
means that i am now technically an
expert in money okay so when i was in
high school i worked at a warehouse
stacking stereo equipment of various
shapes and sizes into semi trucks and
the game was that you had to fill the
semi trucks as much
as possible in order to minimize the
number of semi-trucks that it took
to move the stereo equipment around it
was basically like manual labor tetris
really it was more like manual labor
tetris in an unair-conditioned 110
degree warehouse with a lot of people
yelling at you about how much you suck
at tetris also i made 7.50 an hour which
is by no stretch of the imagination
living wage unless you have someone
paying for your food clothing and
housing okay so let's say you make 7.50
an hour at your crappy summer job that's
a week and take home pay you probably
work about 10 weeks over the summer you
would work 12 but your parents are
making you go on a crappy summer
vacation to like mount rushmore or
something and they're going to fight the
entire time about your dad's driving and
there won't be 3g internet half the time
and you won't be able to talk to your
friends and it's going to suck
on the other hand they did pay for your
diapers all those years ago so 247
a week over 10 weeks i'm not a
mathematician but i think that's 2 470
over the course of the summer of course
you're gonna have to spend some of that
money you got to put aside some money
for hank's new album ellen hardcastle
you're gonna have to see definitely hal
she's probably gonna go out to dinner
with your friends a few times let's say
you know 500 bucks okay so that leaves
you with 1970 this is the part where i
want you to go to the bank and set up an
ira which is not an irish republican
army but an individual retirement
account if you don't live in the u.s
they call it something different but
there are equivalents from brazil to
europe pretty much everywhere hank i'm a
very fancy and highly trained economist
so i'm not sure this explanation is
going to make sense to you but an ira is
essentially a machine that produces
money using nothing but time how does it
do it through the magic of compound
interest so let's say you have a 10
investment that you're somehow making 10
on at the end of the year you've made a
dollar in interest and you have 11
at the end of the next year you get 10
percent of that 11
which is a dollar 10 and your interest
just goes up and up and up and off so
let's say between the ages of 16 and 19
you're able to put away 1970
a year into an ira account and then you
do nothing for 50 years we know that the
world economy grows when adjusted for
inflation about 6.5
a year over the last 100 years that
means that at the end of 50 years when
you retire at the age of 69
your 5910 will have turned into more
than 162
000 and yes i am adjusting for inflation
000 from stupid getting yelled at manual
labor tetris but realistically you
probably can't put away 2 000
this summer i mean you may have to save
for college or you may have to help out
your family you may have to pre-order 26
copies of the fault in our stars so
let's say between the ages of 16 and 21
you put away 400
this summer for a total of 2 000 you
still have more than 50
000 when you retire that means when it's
all said and done you didn't make 750 an
hour of whipping burgers you made 125
an hour but now let's say i tottering
old man that i am at 33 years old put
away 2 000
today i'm still 37 years away from
retirement but what happens if i put
away 2 000
it's only worth 20 000 that's compound
interest at work that's why it's more
important to save early to maximize the
number of years that the interest can
compound than it is to save lots at a
lot of banks you can open up these
accounts for like a hundred dollars and
the bankers are always happy to help you
because they get paid for each account
they open so there really is a way to
turn your crappy summer job into a lot
of money although it's going to take a
while in short hank you don't have to be
a rich person to do the things that rich
people do to maximize their income and
avoid taxes
all right hank before i answer the
pressing question of whether my suit is
all business there is one outstanding
issue
youtube nextup europe there are a lot of
nerdfighters who made it to the voting
round of youtube next up europe
including rosianna who is responsible
for the title of the fault in our stars
i've put links to entries from no
nerdfighters in the doobly-doo it's
really easy you just click thumbs up but
the most important thing is that you
watch
all the videos and vote for your
favorites because you have a chance to
shape the future of youtube and that's
something you should take seriously i
hope that you do
i watched every single video and i hope
you will too i made a poem
it's not i'll see you on wednesday